hey guys this is dennis the founder take
care and i'm david griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is a review of agents of shield episode
19 the only light in the darkness so
this is the one we had talked about amy
acker being cast as agent Coulson's a
girlfriend in this episode and while I
enjoyed this episode I was kind of
disappointed III didn't think it was as
good as the last two episodes that we
had since the captain america you know
movie and this one it did have something
to do with what was going on but it was
a little more episodic plus we didn't
have bill paxton as a villain who i
think is the best part of it and and i
thought they would do more with amy
ackers character as the great friend
they don't even see each other would
know i mean other was interesting
because she's a cellist it was all been
hearing about in the movies and
everything I thought I was in Tokyo so I
still think it's losing steam since
Captain America I think each week is
losing steam I wonder how long they can
keep this going I think we knew bill
paxton was only gonna be in it for think
he signed a four-episode deal so I think
mania bring him baby baby though they
can fit him in the finale somehow after
a late shoot or maybe next season if it
gets renewed uh it was okay i mean i
guess my favorite part of the episode I
kind of like the whole the lie detector
test and begins oh that's some tension i
really like Patton Oswalt he's he's a
funny guy now he's gone he's gone ahead
now he's yeah so I mean but he's fun
he's a good stand-up comedian your love
him and justified to so I like that
moment even the parts with agent grant I
like that like that like when he was
trying to fake it and he admitted to
like you know he's being there for sky
which I guess maybe was one truth of
that whole scenario so that was
interesting I mean there were some
decent parts but again as an episode as
a whole I didn't think it was that even
the new that the guy the new metahuman
you know though the Valan the Marcus
Daniel wasn't kind of fool yes very
forgettable I thought of it he would be
more interesting and I thought that's my
biggest beef was I thought the character
Amy Acker was gonna play was right she
was just like the damsel in distress
that was basically it you know she was
being followed and attacked by this guy
and they had to save her and no you know
we didn't get to see her reunite with
Coulson we didn't call scene I think
they were threw that in there something
that or just to see more about
character you know I know she's a good
actress you know I've seen her in
dollhouse and angel so I know she has it
they didn't really give her much to do
you know maybe in in future episodes
they well but they didn't really with
this one and and I thought yeah they
could have done more with it and I liked
even the the end at least I appreciate
it because you know I think I mean now
you know agent Melinda may has been a
little stagnant Lee it's just kind of
moping around like how come no one
trusts you don't trust me yet and she's
a tough woman so I can't like that she's
kind of packed up and you know left and
just kind of doing her own thing and let
meetup met up with that one at the end
and we'll see you don't know what's
gonna happen that but that well glad
that she I assuming that's her mom I
would guess I think that's her mom I was
also kind of in the world's not in
shield because she said your agency so
right maybe she's in the CIA or summer
Hydra know so it's nice to see at least
her like get up and do something else
and she's searching for Maria Hill yeah
who we know from Captain America is now
assume working for Stark Industries and
yeah that's right at the end of the
movie we also know that I believe she's
Cobie Smulders has stated that she wants
to be in more episodes and it well yes
we saw we saw the preview we see that
she is in the right episode so I think
that was an interesting part of it i met
your mother's gone so maybe she'll she's
got more time just one more time no um
with the whole like grant in sky thing
like you like them going off with like
holding hands at the end of it really
does a little cheesy it's like I also
thought having her figure out that he
was a bad guy so soon I thought they
were gonna let this play out right I
thought like okay but now you know with
because of the ID batches and her fault
finding the dead body everyone else Walt
character Koenig right yeah you know I
thought it was pretty soon I thought
they would play that mouth you just
choose kind of went I meant with it you
know take you know just say like I'm a
bad guy I know I don't care like it is
all that is stupid it is it's a little
cheesy but I think their relationship
has been weak like I said this has been
a long time ago now but I liked when at
least with May in Ward that was kind of
interesting when we first song you know
they were they were sleeping together
but then they've haven't gone back to
that really that's two bags I think
him and sky is too predictable just make
sense they'd be together I don't really
like that scenario no and I don't I
don't feel real big chemistry no Queen
there yeah but I thought it would have
been cool for him to see this double
agent and her not know that let that
play out now it's like this whole thing
where she knows he's a double agent so
in a way she's also pretending right as
well not a double agent but she's kind
of undercover pretending oh oh you're a
good guy well let's go figure this out
so maybe that will play out better and
future episodes I just thought it was
relatively fast yeah we're still I like
like many things are I think I mean I'm
assuming this episode about 3 30
episodes left i'm guessing he gets a
22-episode so I mean this season's
wrapping up i mean i don't i don't know
where it's gonna leave us and we don't
know if they're gonna play off the Hydra
thing all the way until the end I think
so yeah just just use that I guess I
just I say bring back Bill Paxton yeah
Bill Paxton was missed this week he's
missed yeah what do you think of the
whole Fitz and Simmons thing where he's
jealous of her her relationship with
trip yeah I was he freaking about trip
yeah that's the address it doesn't it'll
don't interest me that much they've
always been more the comic relief and
even when they are sometimes really not
that funny I think they're just they're
just not that they're not interesting as
characters to me yeah I think they need
to be given more you know they need to
it's an ensemble cast submitted sighs
cast need to be give them some good
story to do I don't know I just don't
know how do you I mean you would you buy
there i mean it's it's okay i mean it's
the standard stuff we've seen in right i
think that's just an aside probably
doesn't hurt that Simmons is pretty hot
yes is pretty great accent as well the
British yeah got it so maybe that's what
makes me in trip more interesting than I
should be right right yeah but hopefully
they develop things more with with that
and just with the rest of the characters
and hopefully we do see Amy Acker back
in the same role with a better I guess
story arc yeah there's the thing thing
this series is hurt from the most it
just needs just more story more
development more interesting story yeah
less filler and hopefully if they do get
a second season maybe they can
accomplish that okay alright guys so
that's what we thought the episode you
can post your comments below on the
website think hero.com or on our youtube
channel think Harold pro make sure to
subscribe to that you also come check us
out on Twitter talk to dennis michael
myself we're at think hero i'm at
griffin de and we also have a Facebook
page that's facebook.com slash think
hero
fans make sure you like that page and
share our videos on Twitter and Facebook
and all that stuff
you